[Applause]
even in lockdown Britain United for a
moment of solidarity people took to
their doorsteps of windows to applaud
the unwavering resilience of the NHS
[Music]
what started as an idea on social media
captured the hearts of Royals and
celebrities all united in their message
of thanks I'm very emotional when we are
all so grateful to everybody who works
on the front line whether that's in the
NHS or stuck in our supermarkets while
keeping our courts we know people are
just keeping this world going whilst
we're self isolating and keeping
ourselves safe it's a small thing that
we can all get together and hopefully
make them understand and it's everyone
you know it's the doctors the nurses the
cleaners the porters all the unsung
heroes the glittering landmarks of
London also showed their support as did
the Prime Minister and the Chancellor
hours earlier had outlined some
financial relief for the self-employed
to all of those who are self-employed
who were rightly anxious and worried
about the next few months you haven't
been forgotten we will not leave you
behind
and we are all in this together some of
the five million people in the UK who
work for themselves will now be able to
claim up to two thousand five hundred
pounds a month as a new business owner
hairdresser Phil watched the
announcement with bated breath ever
since I started just in 23 years ago
it's been my dream the last couple of
years I've been actively looking to open
the salon and you know I've done my
research I thought I'd done it properly
but obviously it was expecting this to
happen
critics worry that the money won't reach
the self-employed until summer at the
earliest
but with shutters down for the
forseeable it's now that their
businesses need it the most
Ashtyn Aharon AG Sky News